howard i locked eyes
and communicated with a squirrel
i know it is that's why i don't want to
talk about it i don't want any laughter
during it i really want to take this
seriously because i know you're serious
go ahead
i am and it really helps enlighten me so
i meditated
in my chair was saturday morning at 10
a.m
and i woke i came out of my meditation
and on my deck on the ledge of my deck
through my window was a squirrel sitting
there
but howard his back was turned to me
and i thought that was odd because
usually squirrels they run around they
they dart around like the tasmanian
very odd to see a squirrel with his back
do you go right go ahead well just
sitting there without moving right
right so i slowly approached the window
and i i appeared into the window and he
was about
four feet away from me and the squirrel
howard
slowly turned around go ahead
slowly and looked right at me in my eyes
right and what happened and i looked at
the squirrel back
and i i looked at him and the squirrel
just kept studying my face
and i kept studying the squirrel i said
this
is this is unheard of the squirrel was
communicating with me he was showing me
that
nature is important that this is a
message from the universe
that all creatures are important and
that
the impossible is possible a squirrel
would never stop and be
fixated he would slowly the squirrel
waited for me his back was turned he
slowly turned and he looked at me right
in the eye
and we were locked eyes for one minute
straight and it was one of the moments
let me uh
let me yell at jd jd you're laughing
you're not taking this seriously
i just thought it was absolutely my it
was after my meditation howard and it
was just meditation
jd wasn't getting why are you uh why are
you laughing and not thinking
what is so funny why
why do you laugh when sal has a
visitation from a squirrel
obviously there's something funny about
fogging up yeah
sal had an incredible experience he's
sharing it with us
and i'm sorry and it's hard for me to
share this because
no i'm sorry i'm sorry because you guys
like james beautiful moment for sal
i apologize i don't mean to belittle
what you've just said but the idea of a
squirrel turning around
and looking at you doesn't seem all that
unusual i've had that experience a
million times and i didn't give it a
moment's thought you know i mean no but
howard it was a quiet
almost like um moment of enlightenment
the squirrel slowly turned
and and was fixated on me actually when
i passed my window all the birds
you know fly away the squirrels dart
this one was
locked he was what do you think this
world was saying that nature
is uh communication yeah right yeah
yeah the squirrel is saying hey you know
we're all in this together
there's beauty in everything like the
squirrel was saying that i can
communicate with you we can all
the plants the birds the butterflies so
are you eating meat now
are you going to stop still yes
but you learn nothing i can't give up a
meatball parmesan hero
i'm still confused over who had the
moment of enlightenment sal or
i was thinking the squirrel was staring
at soggy's like you know my whole life
i thought like i'd love to be a human
being and not be a squirrel
because we're pretty close to being a
rat and uh
you know except for the fluffy tail
where we're at and i'm looking at this
guy and i'm like you know what i'd
rather be a squirrel